[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm carolina the owner pereira of
lady sea cakes based in los angeles
california and i'm going to show you the
process of making a wedding cake today
let's get started when i get the call
for a wedding cake i know it could go in
so many different directions the
inspirations usually come mostly from
the story of the couple what their
traditions are and i'm trying to design
the kate around that the wedding cake is
going to be the centerpiece of the event
the couple is going to take pictures
next to the cake cutting decay so it has
to be perfect you have to be able to
reflect that story in that cake so they
can have it in that picture forever
i like to have equal
amount of buttercream and cake so the
person that is in the cake is able to
have all the flavors in one bite so you
have to trim the cake and clean it up a
little bit the trick to do it is using a
turntable and always keep the knife in
the same position don't move the knife
just move the turntable and the layers
will be all the same
i usually start with the buttercream
mostly work with swiss meringue burger
cream which is a very silky and smooth
butter cream and one of the things that
my customers love the most is that it's
not oversweet for me it's very important
that the cake will be as good inside as
it is outside as well
[Music]
you cram coat it and put it in the
refrigerator for a little while a few
minutes will work until you can do the
final coat this is one of the most
important parts the cake will reflect
whatever mistakes you're making in the
final coat it will show through the
fondant so it's very important to
achieve your sharp edges or whatever
shape you're looking for in the cake
working with fondant is it could be very
complicated fondant can crack it can
melt and when you start rolling little
air bubbles are start popping up and you
have to try to manage to take them out
because they look horrible in a cake of
course using a little bit of shortening
helps you to keep them moist and fondant
the opposite when the fondant is too
sticky or wet is not easy to work with
you use cornstarch or powdered sugar i
prefer to use cornstarch powdered sugar
to me kind of dries out fondant a little
quicker and it's very trendy right now
to have cakes with sharp edges on the
top one of the ways that it works the
best for me is flipping the cake over
and smooth the fondant once the cake is
upside down which is a little risky and
sometimes it can go wrong all bakers
have different techniques to do
different things i guess i like to live
on the edge all the time and that's kind
of like my thing
i use this technique to kind of have
that look of concrete i will say and
it's a pretty simple technique with thin
foil the result is is very unique and
impressive with a simple thin foil ball
to make the flowers you can always work
in different ways you can do it by hand
or use these amazing tools that we have
these days with different silicone molds
which makes it easier and in this case
the idea of the look of the cake is to
blend those flowers are coming out of
the concrete one of the best ways to
glue fondant with fondant is just a
simple tiny bit of water and that will
act as a glue as soon as it dries out
fondant hates humidity you live in
florida or any other part of the country
that rains all the time it will be very
hard for you to work with fondant i
still these days with all the experience
times that i have to take the fondant
out because it didn't work because the
fondant raped
i love which is very trendy as well to
add little touches of gold using luster
dust with a little bit of vodka it looks
very real
[Music]
the last details of the cake that i used
today i wanted to add a little bit of a
modern twist
so i decided to come with this idea
which is a simple technique but it looks
so beautiful at the end i use wafer
paper you have to be a little more
careful it breaks very easily it's wafer
it's edible
and you simply glue the bottom with a
little bit of popping gel and then place
it on the cake
it's very surprising how people can get
so emotional when they see a cake they
cry i understand but i can't believe it
sometimes
why are they crying you know it's okay
and again i remind myself it's not just
a cake it's what they were telling me
for months you know that they want to
see what they went through it's
incredible it's such an honor to be part
of a celebration like that with one of
my cakes it's beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
you